-A member of the committee
investigating
the January 6th insurrection
revealed what he called the most
chilling moment from that day,
while three more Trump allies,
including Kevin McCarthy
and Marjorie Taylor Greene,
were caught lying about their
roles in the attempted coup.
Oh, and also, Donald Trump said,
in a lawsuit,
that he's afraid of getting hit
with dangerous fruits.
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Every day, it seems like we get
more bombshell reporting
about what happened
on January 6th
and who was involved
and now, on top of everything
else we've already learned,
we have what one member
of the committee investigating
the insurrection called
the most chilling
anecdote yet --
an account of something
Vice President Mike Pence said
in the Capitol
as the riot was unfolding.
-Democratic Representative
Jamie Raskin of Maryland,
who is a member of the House
1/6 select committee,
said the committee's
upcoming public hearings will
"tell a story that will really
blow the roof off the House."
At an event in Washington, D.C.,
Raskin spoke about what he
called a chilling moment
from January the 6th,
involving former
Vice President Mike Pence.
After rioters stormed
the halls of Congress,
some chanting,
"Hang Mike Pence,"
the vice president's
Secret Service agents rushed him
to a secure location
inside the Capitol.
Those agents, who, Raskin says,
he suspects were reporting
to Trump's
Secret Service agents,
then tried to whisk Pence
away from the Capitol.
That's when,
the congressman says,
Pence uttered what he called
"the six most chilling words"
he's heard
throughout this
entire investigation --
"I'm not getting in that car."
-I'm guessing that's when Pence
went into full chameleon mode.
You know that thing he does
where he closes his eyes
[ Laughter ]
and sits totally still,
hoping no one will notice him?
[ As Pence ]
This is not happening.
[ Laughter ]
You are not here.
You are in your happy place,
at a public library,
burning a pile
of "Harry Potter" books.
[ Laughter ]
That's how nefarious
this plot was,
and how deep it went --
Trump's own vice president
suspected the Secret Service
might be involved.
Almost every day, it seems,
more evidence emerges
that implicates yet another
member of Trump's inner circle
and, nearly every day,
those same people
get caught lying about it.
Like Trump's former energy
secretary Rick Perry,
who denied to CNN
that he ever proposed ideas
to Trump's chief of staff
Mark Meadows
for how to overturn
the election results,
before text messages turned up
in which Perry was caught
saying exactly that.
And Perry even went
out of his way to make clear
he was the one writing
the text messages.
-Trump's former
energy secretary Rick Perry,
former governor of Texas,
texted Meadows...
Just for the record,
previously,
we've reported at CNN
another Rick Perry text.
He denied it.
It was his phone.
CNN has confirmed,
from multiple sources,
friends and colleagues of his,
that that is his phone number
these texts were coming from.
In fact, these texts
on the Meadows log show
that he signed his name
[ Laughter ]
and his telephone number
at the end of the text.
-I think, if you're going
to pitch ideas for a coup,
then lie about it, maybe don't
sign your text messages
with your name and phone number.
[ Laughter ]
Did he also send a follow-up
text that said...
[ Laughter ]
I will say,
if you've ever texted
with an older person,
like a parent or an in-law,
you've probably witnessed
the same behavior.
They all sign their text
messages with their names,
like they're writing
Civil War letters home.
[ Laughter ]
[ Southern accent ]
[ Poignant tune plays ]
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
The circle of Trump cronies
involved in the coup
keeps getting wider and wider,
to the point where it seems
like virtually the entirety
of the Trump administration
and his closest allies
in Congress
were involved in some way.
Like Marjorie Taylor Greene,
who we now know
was also texting Meadows,
more than a week
after the insurrection,
about the possibility of Trump
declaring martial law
to stay in power,
an idea that had been advocated
by Trump allies
like Michael Flynn
and Mike Lindell,
only Greene misspelled
the word martial
in the dumbest possible way.
-Three days
before the inauguration,
Marjorie Taylor Greene
sent this text message
to Mark Meadows...
Note on your screen,
she misspells the word martial.
That's right. She spelled it
like the name Marshall.
[ Laughter ]
Now, in her defense,
Marjorie Taylor Greene
probably just confused
martial law
with Marshalls law,
[ Laughter ]
which she violates
every time she tries
to bring more
than six items
into the changing room,
at which point she's escorted
from the store, screaming --
[ As Greene ]
It's my constitutional right
to find comfortable slacks
at a reasonable price!
[ Laughter ]
And then last night,
in an interview with Fox News
host Laura Ingraham,
Greene implied that the
text messages in question
might not even be hers,
while also insisting that,
if they were hers,
she wasn't actually asking
Trump to declare martial law.
She was just letting him know
that it was something
that was being discussed.
-Those are reportedly
my text messages.
I think, if people read them
for themself,
if those were my text messages,
they clearly say that I
wasn't calling for that.
I actually said that's something
I don't know about.
That was what those
text messages say.
-So you didn't advocate --
-Right now, there's a group --
-You never advocated
martial law,
that President Trump
should use martial law
to stop, you know,
the transition of power?
You never advocated
for that, did you?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't recall ever advocating
for martial law.
I think --
I don't know if you have that
up on the screen right now
because I can't see it...
-No.
-...but, if you put
that text message up,
it's clear and easy to read
that, if that's my text messages
and that's what
they're reporting,
I don't recall if they are,
but if they are,
those text messages do not say
calling for martial law.
-So you don't know if the texts,
which you've seen,
were actually yours.
You sound like a werewolf trying
to piece things together
the next morning.
[ Laughter ]
"Look, I don't recall
eating any villagers,
but if that's why there's blood
on my nightshirt,
then I guess I forgot
to chain myself to the bed."
[ Laughter ]
Also, can we go back to this?
-I don't know if you have that
up on the screen right now
because I can't see it.
-No.
-I like that she accidentally
asked Ingraham,
"Are you going to do
any journalism?"
And Ingraham said, "No."
[ Laughter ]
Fox News reacts to the question,
"Are you going
to do journalism?"
the way Larry David reacts
to a dinner invite.
[ Changes accent ]
Larry, you want
to come over tonight?
Come on, I'll drive you.
[ As David ]
Uh...
I'm not getting in that car.
[ Laughter ]
They all do the same thing --
lie, get caught lying,
then talk in nonsense
word-salad circles
of inscrutable bull[bleep]
to try to get out of it.
The same thing happened
with House GOP leader
Kevin McCarthy,
after he denied a report
that he told fellow Republicans,
in the days
after the insurrection,
that he would urge Trump
to resign.
And then audio surfaced
of the phone call
in which McCarthy said
he would urge Trump to resign.
After the audio surfaced,
McCarthy held a press conference
where he tried to claim
he hadn't lied
when he denied
the initial report,
but his answer made
no sense, whatsoever.
-The reporter never asked me
that question.
The reporter came to me
the night before he
released the book
and my understanding was
he was saying
that I asked President Trump
to resign.
No, I never did,
and that's what I was answering.
If you're answering --
If you're asking now,
did I tell my members
that we're going to ask,
ask them if I told any of them
that I said President Trump.
The answer is no.
-Your claim is
that you weren't lying
when you deny that you said
you would urge Trump to resign
because the reporter asked you
if you urged Trump to resign,
which you claim you didn't,
and, if we want to know
if you told your members
you would urge Trump to resign,
we should ask your members
if you told them
you would urge him to resign,
instead of just listening
to the audio
where you told them
you would urge Trump to resign.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like I just spent an hour
trying to find an exit
in an M.C. Escher painting.
[ Laughter ]
Why would we ask your members
if you said it?
We have the audio
of you telling your members
impeachment would pass
and Trump should resign.
That wasn't me!
That was my friend...
[ Laughter ]
Here's my question
about everything we've learned,
so far.
In addition to being
horrifying and dangerous,
why is everything always
so incredibly stupid?
Has it always been this way?
Whenever you watch old movies
about politics,
like "Mr. Smith Goes
to Washington"
or "All the President's Men,"
it all seems so noble
and dignified.
I can't imagine there's
old newsreel footage
of Harry Truman moving around
to a Village People song.
-♪ It's fun to stay at the ♪
♪ YMCA ♪
♪ It's fun to stay at the ♪
[ Laughter ]
-For example,
the news found a way
to get even dumber this week,
when newly released excerpts
from a deposition reveal
that Donald Trump said
he was afraid
that protesters,
during the 2016 election,
would throw dangerous fruits
at him during a rally.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
That's -- and that's why we
had the security guards.
[ Laughter ]
Now, me, I wanted --
I wanted to use some very highly
specialized fruit ninjas.
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Let's do ninjas
because they have
the fruit swords."
But they said no because,
if they miss three fruits,
they're out and you can't --
[ Laughter ]
You can't show weakness
like that.
[ Laughter ]
And then there's this,
even dumber,
part of the deposition,
where Trump says...
[ Laughter ]
What do you mean, do fruit?
What do you mean,
you were put on alert?
There's an alert system
for fruit?
It's like the Homeland Security
threat level.
Red's tomato,
yellow's for banana,
and green is for
[ As Trump ] avocado.
[ Laughter ]
And you know what they say --
If you get hit with an avocado,
you're toast.
[ Laughter ]
And that's today's brunch joke.
[ Clink ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you.
Also, how would somebody
sneak a pineapple
into a political rally?
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, you misheard.
This isn't a pineapple.
This is my baby.
Her name is, uh, Penelope.
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that right, Penelope?
Oh, Penelope has dry skin.
We need some lotion.
[ Laughter ]
Aah!"
[ Thud ]
[ Laughter ]
These idiots are somehow
both the dumbest
and most dangerous people
in our politics.
When they're not panicking
about potential
fruit-based assaults,
they're actively planning
to subvert free
and fair elections.
They did it in 2020.
They were caught, lied about it,
and they're preparing
to do it again, as we speak.
Democracy is the Target
and they've sunk to new Lowe's,
including declaring...
-Martial law.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheering and applause ]
Let's move on.
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.